boa noite a dar bem a propósito esse
espaço cultural chama-se ariano suassuna
e eu gostaria de começar contando a
minha história a vocês contextualizando
no brasil
ariano suassuna que nós sabemos
reconhecidamente é um excelente
fantástico e maravilhoso escritor nos
deixou recentemente gostava muito de ir
ea mercados são josé em recife
lá ele ouviu os cantadores tomar caldo
de cana e sempre todos os domingos
quando ele chegava encontrava um pedinte
cego que a quem ele dava esmola isso ele
fez durante muito tempo durante muitos
anos a ponto do pedinte já identificar
pelos passos a chegada de adriano os
anos depois de terminado domingo o
pedinte ouvir os passos identificou está
a ser o adriano que bom que está aqui
sabe segue o que é esse ano eu queria
falar com o senhor negócio estou muito
precisar de conversar com os senhores
pois não sabe o que quer e deseja se
olhando o seguinte eu tô precisando que
o senhor me adiante quatro semanas de
esmola porque eu vou tirar um mês de
férias
o brasil é isso isso o brasil um pouco
daqui foi contado aqui está muito isso e
é nesse contexto a minha família viveu
ela foi talvez a família mais rica da
paraíba meus pais principalmente na
década de 70 até 80 e eles tinham até
porque é necessário lembrar para os mais
jovens que até 1970 paraíba não tinha
hotel joão pessoa não tinha hotel e como
a casa dos meus pais eram a casa enorme
mensalão enfrenta o clube cabo branco na
descida das pessoas nove suítes as
coisas estúpidas mil metros de área
todas as pessoas importantes as
autoridades artistas ficavam hospedados
na casa dos meus pais
eu conheci pessoalmente dos presidentes
da república lá na sala todos os
artistas que você possa imaginar da
época passaram por lá e meus pais tinham
a preferência é muito clara
pelo que eles queriam na vida eles
queriam que eu fosse ele e os outros
filhos mas é o mais velho eles é o teve
o atrevimento de ser a coisa mais
importante que alguém pode ser um filho
de pai rico se você se procurarem uma
profissão que não ser advogado do mesmo
jeito vai nada bom é ser filho de rico
porque não queira ser rico o rico se
preocupa e empregar gasta é pagar
imposto
zelar pelo patrimônio o filho de rico só
tem uma preocupação gastar dinheiro
início era perito
mas olha eu morei no rio de janeiro
morei em londres morreu em roma
morei na grécia e em um belo dia recebi
uma ligação de meus pais 1979 venha pra
cá que tem um negócio muito ruim
na época eu não queria hoje em dia
graças a deus eu sou super bem casado
hoje em dia mas eu vim eu vim pra joão
pessoa ea notícia é muito simples o
governo brasileiro havia no dia 7 de
dezembro de 79 a criado uma coisa muito
bonita chamada maxidesvalorização da
moeda do dia pra noite meus pais que
nomes empreendimentos aqui eles tinham
processos terem idéia a primeira loja
com escada rolante construída aqui foi
deles depois foi mesmo a hoje eu nem sei
o que lá três andares ar condicionado
central 60 a idéia como a cidade era
atrasada
minha mãe meu pai tiver que contratar
dois professores de escada rolante para
ensinar o povo a andar na escada que
ninguém sabia é verdade
então é uma inovação muito grande para a
cidade e de repente todos esses
investimentos tinham dúzia tem um
empreendimento imobiliário 184
apartamentos cinco mansões
tudo isso acabou da noite pro dia nós
acordamos sem nada mas sem nada mesmo e
eu vou dizer pra vocês que quiser que
elogia
empresa eu respeito profundamente e não
tenho medo de voltar a ser pobre mas eu
não posso me acostumar
eu tenho que procurar sair foi o que eu
fiz a partir daquele dia eu tive que
fazer duas coisas básicas primeiro como
meus pais não tinham um tostão para
pagar advogado e vai fazer vestibular de
direito está bem próximo do ex parceiro
investidor nós no vestibular
comecei a cursar direito para defender o
patrimônio dos meus pais a família
inteira e era uma agonia muito grande
porque ao mesmo tempo em que eu tinha
que estudar direito e fazem as petições
que pedia emprestado aos amigos máquina
de escrever códigos que não tinha
dinheiro para comprar e fazer nos
escritórios de um de outro sempre
pedindo emprestado tudo e graças a deus
sendo bem atendido
ao mesmo tempo fazia que me manter eu
tenho que cuidar de filhos e aí o que eu
ia fazer as minhas habilidades é
fantástico saber gastar dinheiro que aí
não dá dinheiro para nada já não tinha
segundo eu sabia tocar piano e eu sempre
gostei muito de conversar
então o que é que eu fiz eu inventei
aqui na paraíba uma coisa chamada bolsa
de telefones eu comprava e vendia
telefones à noite eu tocava piano num
restaurante lá da praia e minha mãe
inventou entre muitas atividades um
negócio que hoje existem restaurantes
fazendo que a prova seja caipira
só que funcionava no domingo lá em casa
mostrava gravamos um pouquinho
congregações e no nas festas do clube
que era o clube mais luxuoso daqui onde
anteriormente tinha sido rei da noite e
vender sopa na porta não tinha problema
nenhum nunca tive constrangimento com
isso o grande problema é que quando você
fica pobre você adquire um superpoder
você se torna invisível você fica na
fila de 11 a 21 11 ponto de ônibus
e você vê todos os seus amigos passando
de carro e ninguém vê ninguém para lhe
dar uma carona
muito tempo depois quando eu readquirir
a minha visibilidade um amigo confessou
rapaz eu devia realmente lá mas não
parar porque você ficar constrangido
isso é conversa de quem já viu pobre
não existe isso não meu amigo e pior eu
era o pior tipo de pobre que existia
porque eu fui um pobre com bom gosto
horas eu tinha sido rico eu sabia o que
era bom então por exemplo vou dar um
exemplo muito simples pra vocês
pão com mortadela quando eu comia pão
com mortadela na época da pobreza
extrema e era raro comer pão com a
tabela mortadela aquela mortadela cheia
de gordura a a ao redor dela parece que
tem um fio de nylon era um negócio
território ficar me lembrando da
mortadela italiana que eu comia antes e
rap
a manteiga misture a manteiga margarina
resolve o próprio pão não era mais
aquele pontos e tenho mais
através desses desses momentos de
trabalho e principalmente tocando piano
nesse restaurante que eu falei pra vocês
e uma noite fui procurado no piano por
um cidadão que depois eu soube que era
presidente do tribunal superior do
trabalho ministro presidente que veio
aqui para instalar
o trt tribunal regional do trabalho da
paraíba estou falando em 1985
ao final da noite tocamos bastante ele
gostava de bossa nova no final daquele
grupo
o próximo presidente que seria
presidente aquino tribunal só olha
fulano emprega esse rapaz que toda vez
que eu venho aqui eu quero encontrar com
ele então o primeiro emprego e um
emprego público que eu tive na minha
vida porque seis meses depois eu saí e
já vou dizer porque o primeiro emprego
foi assessor para tocar piano para o
ministro só só minha função era só
esperar o momento não me disse que eu ia
lá pegava mas é uma coisa interessante
porque nesse tempo eu comecei a
desenvolver a amizade com esses juízes
desembargadores e servidores do tribunal
mundo e comecei a conseguir deles causas
para advogar por que até então só tinha
meu pai eu não tinha mais ninguém
cliente grande cliente ou quebrar foi
trabalhar patrão pobre é pedir esmola
para 2 não queiram mais bem o que é que
aconteceu eu comecei com esse ministro
colocou com esse presidente e com os
juízes a construir um rol de amizades
e de interesses comuns eles começaram a
confiar em mim para as causas pequenas
no começo há alguém que há um acidente
automóvel um despejo uma aquisição de um
imóvel enfim coisas mínimas mas aí
surgiu um seis meses de tribunal uma
grande causa uma ação que pretendia
demitir todos os servidores do tribunal
porque não entraram por concurso só que
nós temos 85 a constituição de 88 e
enfim eu tomei uma grande atitude na
minha vida eu não tenho condição de
servidor público vou advogar para esse
pessoal mas o contrato como era eu só
poderia receber alguma coisa deles ao
final da causa e se desse certo que esse
foi um dos demitidos e recebeu que aviso
prévio também não tem sentido não é
verdade então eu partirei para essa
advocacia intensa e comecei a trabalhar
e trabalhei bastante não só nesse caso
como nos casos que a repercussão daquele
momento deu porque se notícia começou a
sair nos jornais e que em época de
emitir 500 pessoas de uma vez só saiu a
liminar eu fui tão bem mas é uma
confusão
mas aí chegou um terceiro momento
importante da minha vida
a necessidade que eu tive que inventar a
minha fama porque não duvida em qualquer
de vocês qualquer pessoa no mundo que
queira ser alguma coisa de destaque na
profissão que escolheu não tem
necessidade somente estudar e se phd
aliás nem precisa dessas especificidades
todas porque o que importa é que você
tenha clientes que adianta você saber da
maior tese de engenharia do mundo se
reinventa e contrata é ficar o dia
inteiro em casa com um caderninho não
tem sentido então um mês ea mim inventar
e termos de fama e o que é que eu fiz eu
procurei saber comigo mesmo
quais os momentos que poderiam ser
revista para projetar meu nome no
mercado e quando alguém pensar se eu
estou com um problema jurídico não tem
aquele advogado que é bom pelo menos o
jornal dci
eu me lembrei que eu havia sido
testemunha de um crime no rio de janeiro
terrível susan jul efe o filme música e
eu fui a testemunha que reverteu o caso
o incidente não é não era original só
estava no lugar no momento em que
aconteceu e eu fui a comissão da verdade
enfim isso virou a história daquele
momento das páginas policiais
brasileiras e políticas e através desse
destino eu conhecia filha dos azul
edgard que era na época o jornalista e
ela me abriu assim portas fantásticas
tanto profissionalmente como
economicamente porque todo mundo que do
círculo de amizade dela que tinha
problema jurídico na paraíba passou a
vir pro meu escritório isso representava
muito pra eles porque são empresas
paguem muito pequenina é um favor que
eles faziam pra ela mas pra mim começou
a sobrevivência ea partir daí eu comecei
a aproveitar todas as minhas
oportunidades um dia eu pensei por que
todo mundo tem um livro eu não tenho o
livro não sabia que eu ia escrever
escrever alguma coisa sobre direito mas
eu não tinha mestrado doutorado nada
então escreveu o livro mais básico do
mundo chamado um livrinho de marcos
pires que ensina advogados iniciantes a
cobrar honorários andar com roupa limpa
enfim bobagens a estar lá é meu livro e
porque o livrinho de marcos pires porque
meus amigos com certeza diriam olha o
livrinho de marcos pires já meus
inimigos é um livrinho de marcos pires
ficou livre de marcos pires mas eu
precisava lançar esse livro no mercado e
não conhecia gente suficiente para
encher uma kombi
quanto mais o auditório é verdade e eu
me lembrei que outro amigo de outras
eras naquele momento era ministro
presidente do tribunal superior do
superior tribunal de justiça stj
ministro humberto gomes de barros
isso é certo nem ea lagoa escreveu umas
dezenas de livros alguns jogos outros
científicos mas eu fui atrás dele só o
ministro anunciou que lançou um livro na
paraíba e em resumo convencer o ministro
que o povo do aparelho estava louco para
conhecer o livro de ninguém nem sabia
quem era iraque mas ele convenceu sair o
que já que ele topou de ministros uma
coisa melhor ainda
o senhor vai lançar o seu livro eu vou
lançar meu livro vamos fazer a mesma
festa
quando ele abriu um sorriso de
satisfação meu coração explodiu de
alegria por uma razão não paguei um
tostão para lançar o livro eu peguei o
com o seu marido e eu peguei uma carona
no na festa do ministro aí governador
presidente tudo que ela tribunal julgue
que enchemos a fundação josé américo já
tinha fila mas aí chegou o meu último
gol do ex ministro
vamos fazer uma coisa já que não conhece
muita gente aqui vamos combinar assim o
senhor só vende livro a quem comprar o
meu e eu só vendo a quem comprar os seus
maravilha prontos mas só queria comprar
o livro do ministro mas o resultado
vendemos os livros bastante livre para o
lançamento do que uns 15 mil reais de
lucro saímos eu é e minha esposa ele a
esposa dele e nós fomos jantar no
restaurante só os 4 quando terminou
aquela noite eu estava com dinheiro no
bolso ainda prestar conta ele
só que todo mundo que estava na festa
achou que o jantar no restaurante cruz
fazia parte da festa e todo mundo foi o
restaurante resultado a conta veio pra
mim né 25 mil que nós ganhamos a conta
pois e 200 mil r 600 ainda mas tudo bem
isso aconteceu e aconteceu por bem
aconteceu por melhor porque eu comecei a
crescer na profissão de tal modo isso
aconteceu que eu tenho alguns anos
depois comecei a ver que eu precisava
cuidar mais de mim e de minha saúde abre
novos horizontes sempre foi um
caminhante sempre foi participante de
muita atividade esportiva eu já fiz o
caminho de santiago de compostela quatro
vezes
eu atravessei a ilha da páscoa pé é eu
tenho muita muita coisa eh eh pra dizer
desse ponto mas o mais importante eu me
preocupei com tudo isso e esqueci a
saúde
fui fazer um checkup e disseram no
hospital senhor vai ter um avc
agora tem aqui porque se o hospital
melhor hospital do mundo para tratar do
abc diz que não tem conceitos e tá me
dando não quero ter a versão faz uma
coisa diminua 15 quilos e deixe de comer
sal
me joguei em uma atividade física tão
intensa tão grande que em três meses eu
tinha emagrecido seis quilos
nesse ponto eu fui absolutamente
irresponsável não consultei afora
musculação mas a parte colorida não
consultei profissionais entre cunha 20
quilômetros por dia de manhã e à noite e
sem eu baixei meu tempo metade era uma
coisa estúpida e um dia me acordei com
duas hérnias de disco uma próprios ou em
uma contusão era pra nunca mais pisar no
chão mas aí eu comecei a fazer todo o
tipo de tratamento que é possível todos
todos o que me recomendavam oi de banho
de sal grosso
a massagem o que mosseau solo também a
extrema unção mas tudo no mundo todo
mundo eu fiz para melhorar a dor que é
uma do cachorro da moléstia
eu nunca vi e resumo eu voltei me
recuperei e comecei a atividade física
recomecei a há a fazer minhas musculação
enfim fazer tudo e o resultado que eu
vou mostrar pra vocês é que há 20 dias
atrás eu consegui voltar a correr
ganhei nessa categoria o primeiro lugar
essa categoria é maior de 60 anos
nascido no mira mais filho empresa biz
que era um bem precioso
eu eu preciso terminar quero agradecer a
vocês mas eu gostaria de lembrar
finalmente há o ariano suassuna ariano
sempre disse que é falta de educação
você falar mal dos outros pela frente
não deve não só deve falar mal dos
outros pelas costas pelo amor de deus
então eu tô pedindo a vocês uma coisa
nem que seja por educação na minha
frente button palma no de vergonha não
obrigado
já o pessoal muito obrigado muito
obrigado do fundo do coração aha